you did spend some time working in
Silicon Valley the early part of your
move into the I don't know business
world whatever he's just serving to
describe that experience to us yeah well
I worked up here let's see
late 80s for like 87 as an engineer and
part of 88 I guess yeah I don't know it
was uh wasn't a great experience for me
but I got a lot of comedy material out
of it
for later for movies like office space
and then this TV show Silicon Valley but
I lived in East Palo Alto and briefly in
Sunnyvale and worked at a couple
different places if you were starting
out now the way Silicon Valley is now do
you think you would have stayed a little
bit longer I think I might have yeah I
think I actually I could almost if I'd
been born 25 years later almost see
myself maybe doing a start-up kind of
thing because it's just it's a different
world now it's easier to you can start
it smaller with less resources less
money it's easier to get funded I think
than it was back then so it's like a
lower barrier to entry to do that kind
of thing now did a lot of research for
the show spoke to for example venture
capitalists what was the takeaway from
that what did you learn I mean I think
this is one of those shows where the
more research you do the more I the more
you realize how much there is comedy
wise to do with this area you know we
came in with certain ideas about oh
let's do a story about this let's do a
story about that and as we started
asking questions about well how would
that work every time we talk to somebody
you know practically everything they
said you go oh my god that's so much
funnier than what we had and that's a
better story idea and we can't even fit
that one in you know we get another
season we're gonna have to do that
season two you've you've said that if
that happens you might get into some of
the bigger issues I mean obviously
people talk about you know starting up a
business and innovative products and all
the money you can make but in the valley
right now they talk about things like
the income gap they talk about you know
women and their role in Silicon Valley
so I got the sense to serve some other
deeper themes that you my
want to explore potentially yeah and
these are a lot of things that have just
come up since we started shooting
basically I mean the stuff for the
Google buses and all that that's kind of
brand-new so yeah there's just plenty of
material out there so hopefully we do
another one speaking of Google Google's
executive chairman Eric Schmidt has a
cameo in a party scene you did get
feedback from him on you know authentic
that was what did he tell you yeah that
was very encouraging when he showed up
to shoot he kind of looked around and he
said I've been to this party which was
great affirmation for us there are
references in the show to Steve Jobs
true sleep Steve Jones could you have
done the show without making references
to specific people that was that
integral yeah I mean I think yeah I
suppose but but you know it's it's you
know everyone's got Macs and PCs and
it's so everywhere that if you try to
make up pretending there and there's
pretend companies to but we we just kind
of they coexist in this and yeah that
was it just seemed right asked me with
nine times f is it's 11:00 to 5:00
what do you think it is about your show
that will make it different but then
maybe some of the other attempts we did
an enormous amount of research and he
really tried to get all of the very
subtle details as right as we could and
so I do feel like there's a there's a
nuance to reality that we've gotten in
our show and also I think we just we
wanted to make it as funny and just as
enjoyable as possible hopefully that's
why people watch it not because it's
technically correct but because it's
just a really enjoyable experience
speaking of funny actors like TJ Miller
who plays one of the central characters
he said you told him that you were
looking for that character you were
looking for sort of a Penn Jillette type
now I know you've got your your sort of
your roots and animation how house well
specific do you get on what someone
should look like and what does somebody
from Silicon Valley look like to you I
guess
funny because sometimes I am very
specific about what somebody should look
like but TJ I get that that was in the
script just kind of like sometimes to
just put a description when you haven't
cast anybody you're just trying to paint
a picture or whatever and that was in
there I told GJ you don't have to put on
weight for this and say no no no it's
cool don't worry I was like no but you
really don't know no I know no I'll do
it man
TJ got fat I didn't ask him to what has
this experience been like for you guys
that's been great for me I mean HBO's
been wonderful and supportive they were
amazingly supportive every step of the
way to the point where they were so
unintrusive that it's actually sort of a
bummer because if the show doesn't work
it's kind of a hundred percent are
multiples I think there's no way we can
blame anyone else for it so there is
sort of downside